anything thank you what is that it's my
baby boy what is it where they come from
what is it from don't you know
Cabbage Patch farmer you come then we
have experimented me he's looking at
what can discuss was about one in the
hatch welcome back to the Jenna and
Julian and marbles and the penguin karma
in peace podcast I said we shall have
dogs in the room today
alright so now instead of hearing
barking from off in a distance you'll
hear it right up close by tiny or most
likely crying they want attention
speaking of crying instead of crying get
yourself some naturebox go to nature of
are calm so bad guys male dogs they make
smart delicious smacking very easy they
recently sent us 20 bags 20 bags of the
strawberry fruit stars and how many we
like probably five or six we're plowing
our way through like I thought it wasn't
that really yeah Thank You naturebox for
being the best in the whole world
sending us 20 bags of my favorite snacks
you guys let's go to naturebox.com/tyler
and julian get 50% off right now and get
yourself some me Andy Zelda your
underwear game to the next level with me
Andy's the softest underwear in the
world three times softer than cotton and
sweet designs I actually saw their new
pizza design I really want those those
are sick and you can get them right now
by going to me undies calm fashion
Angeline get 20% off your first pair
plug it up Candace hook it up look it up
again so we Polly we are doing sort of a
hybrid of two things today for the
podcast
last week we did Jenna trivia so I felt
like it was only appropriate to return
the favor this week and do some julienne
trivia I feel like I'm not going to do
well at any of you do yeah so so here's
the thing though we don't have Debbie
here it's just us too so I was thinking
we do half the podcast with Julianne
trivia where Jenna has to guess the
answers to trivia questions about me in
my life and then the rest of the podcast
I spent some time this morning compiling
a list
of Sandom names but youtubers call their
fans and also their intros and like
taglines that they do in their videos
and a lot of these I didn't know but I
got I went on into the lab and a lot and
then for this part of pockets there are
some fake ones spliced in emacs [ __ ] so
you have to guess who it is or if it's
faked and I want to see how you do
there's a lot of really [ __ ] easy
like basic ones yeah I don't know build
[ __ ]
so we'll start would you Lee interview I
get you warmed up I know all the
youtubers I don't know see that's not
fair well you know one wife ain't sure I
say that's not fair is if you like 12
music trivia lungile he has no idea this
is my first time for some payback here
I'm going to sit my ta hey
fresh-squeezed orange juice and let's
get into it
wait so which is first Julianne trivia
or stand up Julian most are Brazilian
boost your confidence a little bit right
before we slap it all the way down if I
do badly on Julian trivia that
confidence to you I have a couple
answers for some of these two and this
is Dada Dada come back Julian trivia
where Jenna have to guess everything
about me and if she doesn't it's done
[Laughter]
okay question number one what did I
dress up as for a year straight as a
child a ninja turtle on rollerskates
Superman Wolf Wolf rocky road those are
right though you have pieces of correct
bits okay but notice my man with roller
skates on enjoy yourself a deeper hole
were you talking about both of those are
right you said a ninja turtle
yeah with roller skates on they were
ninja terrorists river rollerskates I
wasn't rendering in no battement okay
and then our end a year of Batman and
then a year Robin by Jerry to end
one oh no you would not really your face
my acceptable answers were Batman or
Robin or if you mentioned the ninja
toros kids but I did mention the Ninja
Turtle no you you did you never have a
point if you want to have a point here
you go EU I hasten I'm going to enjoy
this episode I think I really did enjoy
oh damn it question number two what did
I hit my brother in the head with on a
family trip um a small statue of the
statue of weird evening nice you guys
were in New York in New York City super
[ __ ] up to look like marble basically
knocked in the head of it you're such a
[ __ ] that could like kill someone yeah
he's fine
hi is evil and maybe we'll see I guess
in a couple years
Congrats out tomorrow by the way he
graduated college this weekend hey I
actually got a sunburn from Marlins
graduation he hacked his way to a
college degree yeah he's a professional
hacker now he's a degree in hacking all
right dad ass so you got 125 minutes he
got one point five degree in hacking bad
ass you want to go up here come on are
you ready TAC yell [ __ ] like this okay
if I don't poop don't finish everything
say she's such a degenerate League
noises can I just say we sometimes we
open the front door and let them run
around the front yard and you guys know
that she does this thing called Pelican
where she likes to take her food kibble
and then run away from her dish like
wherever we are and then eat it like
she's social leader yeah like she that's
like very instinctual though she doesn't
want to like eat alone just in case
somebody else is going to come steal it
you know or whatever it is
so she was running around outside a
little pony like Midas eyes more
instancing around come around the front
yard and then she runs to be inside of
the door drops her kids whooping
succeeding it
who's she Pelican outside and then ate
it in the front door like she was
sprinting with like seven little pieces
of cable in their minds like Pelican
level ten savage like she's she's flying
north for the winter with a line north
or south south they fly south she was
flying south for the winter with a
mouthful of food
miss depends where they're migrating but
it's always sells I don't know they're
flying at South by Southwest for the
winter okay all right
question number three how many career
home runs did I hit all this is hard is
that like career like you're hired babe
and career no it's not it's an easy
answer
you'll get it come on 24 where the [ __ ]
I'm not [ __ ] Mark McGwire that 24
your whole life 24 I had to my whole
life your whole life to it okay I'm
gonna be as open as possible when I say
this year but it's not softball the
fences are not that close
oh I'm sorry no no I'm sorry the years
did you play baseball like 15 okay
you're telling you 15 years you hit two
home runs yes it was not a boner that it
ridiculous it's not ridiculous
ridiculous not ridiculous I'm proud of
my baseball career I'll have you know
and I had and I hit them in two and the
best times my senior year when I was
actually coming into my own as a real
Authenticator not something you hit like
a season it is not so small you can't
relate to do sports defense is not a
hard to deal with when you're a kid
there is no fence generally what I do we
wait when there's a rumor kid there is
no fence IV seen are literally field
there's there's no because I mean grow
up in Southern California I grew up in
upstate New York while we play in the
middle of a [ __ ] couch not my fault
that you guys don't have organized
fields for your sport no we don't
because we're not rich people okay what
performance okay John listen to a rich
versus poor debate don't you dare we
have senses on our baseball field in
Little League
I do not mean we were reaching that we
didn't even in college are you kidding
me we shared a field like we got
insanely high school and college ball
and never no fantasy everyone we did
home runs every day like you hit it past
the outfielder and it goes down a hill
thank you 24 over the course of 15 years
that's a pretty solid guess no no you're
not a power hitter but that too is
ridiculous you know what wait till in
order for you to hit a home run even
when you're like 6 years old you have to
hit it outside of a fence
yes that's what is that is ridiculous no
it's not you can totally have all guys
are coming to you inside the park home
and they're great oh god my head and
I've altered a
I need some comments like down below
because we're both ballplayers and like
yeah but you're wearing you know what
their differences your any of the fields
that we played on there was no offense
okay can we just like kind of desert its
rebel we want to Greek and then
everyone's [ __ ] half of the sport it's
not that's the earth dropping like a
frozen pond I'm hiding up it's just like
sucked okay but it's the highest level
of that sport are there pawns in the
outfield no there's a fence but there's
I was like maybe in your college or high
school career maybe two huh maybe to be
realistic for like your whole life hold
on okay you know what just chill out on
[ __ ] on my offensive hitting I was
not a power hitter I hear a lot of
doubles and singles and I'm proud of
that but let me just say something I
played on maybe three fields in my whole
life without offense literally high
school everything included so everything
happens I'd say it's not just rich
people things you go to a horrible towns
of a handful based on this have you seen
hardball they had an outfield fence now
we got a B that was not a river [ __ ]
town no I'm gonna press you baby in
event [ __ ] a we going cuz they need it
you need to check yourself here can you
check yourself here because two home
runs while it is low it is not a
laughable amount of home run they were
the famous I was just surprised that's
all I needed that clarification the key
element before playoff games in college
we used to watch a because we have to
stay in and wake up super [ __ ] early
we would all say and together and watch
baseball movies that was like a marketer
knows all four movies pretty much we can
only watch a league of their own so nice
I like that's actually a baseball movie
though it is it's a baseball all about
girls Yeah right it's a great movie is
that Julia Roberts in it wasn't
interested in fact it what's another
with it oh [ __ ] Julia Roberts and
league of their own was a home Madonna
no no the doctor girl the girl we need a
peasant's doer little yes oh no sugar
those screws them through a little do
you not know the difference between
Julia Roberts and Jesus I think they
just look like I can I can identify Gina
day but she was in Stuart little I mean
that's
cinematic oh that's a caramel teacher oh
no in the history of cinema stop we are
not doing oh you're not doing this this
is my episode to embarrass you
oh no moving on can ruin in the comments
congratulate me on my two home run
because now I'm really upset about it
what is my favorite food past or present
so multiple answers sushi and sushi [ __ ]
got it
correct I know correct
it's still sushi you just make it vegan
yeah and you know what what I miss it
that's the one thing that I like get
triggered by seeing pictures up yeah
after being amount
all y'all vegans can understand
sometimes like you don't want to eat the
the meter the animal but you still
triggered by food you know yeah sushi is
something insane gets triggered
how old was I when I got diagnosed with
celiac disease uh you were a sophomore
in high school so maybe 15 nice and rekt
actually was the summer before my
sophomore year you know but I was 15s
all right calm down who's my first pet
and what animal was it hold on he's like
I was out fifteen when I was a sophomore
in high school I turned 16 when I was a
kid I was 14 oh you turned 16 when you
were 14 oh no when I was a junior in
high school I'd ya you graduated early
of everything right so right let's not
rub it in for the rest of us normal
plebs seventeen yeah I didn't turn
eighteen until I was at collar at the
stroke the turn eighteen my senior year
of high school yeah um your first pet
I'll give you multiple answers for this
since I might not have told you about
this yeah you might not have because I
know you had a parakeet I don't know
like if you're counting like a family
pet I don't mind my first time hmm Kenny
yes and there's a panicky yeah to
Perkins first one was Jenny's second was
poppy yeah damn I didn't think I thought
you're gonna get poppy I was so good
thanks sounds good you know what helps
is building on equation of all drawn
portrait of you with your parakeet as a
child in our Hall of Fame bathroom
Julian yeah rest in [ __ ] peace she
was great
our like our favorite working bathroom
in this house is the one downstairs in
our plumbing in your foot if you have
really terrible but if you've seen a
Julien's vlog like a long time ago me
and Brett like Julian had like a stack
of all these pictures and paintings when
things for when he was a caddy that he
didn't want to hang them up but he
didn't want to get rid of them in order
to keep them so me and Brett secretly
went in that powder room and like
terrific and so [ __ ] off with Julian's
old paintings and drugs it's amazing in
there that's where the the CJ you're
cool yeah Justin Cooper from lilac and
say hi and Jay Jay Michael J Fox is in
there so I'm Adam his little signatures
from people that your dad got you is
really ready all right moving on again
what a guy Freddy's Almeida Johnny just
got to spend a lot of time with my dad
this weekend hello Philomena
what was my high school mascot well no
no no dude I'm literally met me I know
that your college mascot was the
Panthers right
Chapman yes I'm and other campuses Sam
oh hi I want to say like warrior but I
don't [ __ ] know if I'll ever give me
a second
hmm it's not as stupid as the Brian
Behrens I know that for sure yeah it's
hard to be as stupid as that ah
no offense is on our baseball field i
bender your field to UM [ __ ] I don't
know mortars final answer yeah warriors
hate you Viking
sorry Mikey with spikes right baby I
know it was the horns up I know it
wasn't like an animal or anything I just
sorry I blew it
yeah that was weird I got caught you'd
get that sorry and no it's not like you
where Sam Oh Viking [ __ ] I literally
have worn
my samurai shorts probably one can we
cheer for 30 years
yes 1525 you don't have any kind of like
it doesn't say what your school is thank
you and Isaac says SM gay rights justice
SM I know me you don't know cuz you said
oh my god okay you know what is my
favorite lift what does that mean
I can't hear it lift dad left mm-hmm
correct
you got it that would have been a
breakup worthy mess alright I've broken
how many bones member one zero [ __ ]
never brother bone yeah but on bones is
it is it because you never went to a
doctor cuz I feel you've broken a rib
before yeah you pop ridge okay but that
cow floating rib is not a broken rib
okay loading rip I've never cracked out
of me maybe I have I don't think I broke
a bone wait
I was unfair currently my favorite drink
at bucks mmm I feel like this is a trick
question
I just want answers very clear you know
it I think it's green tea oh is that
nitro cold yes it's my trophy yeah but
you've been ordering a lot of green tea
is not fair I'm gonna take you 24 home
runs for a lifetime all right we're
moving on okay you're doing okay and by
okay I mean you're doing well what is my
blog camera setup [ __ ] a man okay you
have a road bike but I don't know the
numbers and letters associated there's
no numbers or it's just a name okay this
is so unfair you have it a Sony a 7x you
have a little cage on it that you just
twenty-eight 787s okay and your little
mic on there that's circular and alums I
this [ __ ] up
I'm sorry setting on every day I use one
lens for vlogging this isn't fair you
don't have to see your Parliament I owe
you an SD card great that honestly feels
like justice to feel that closest he's
my hand to fill yeah but isn't just
float I'm you have a it has an f-stop of
[ __ ] 24 I would be horrible you can't
own anything with that I don't know babe
I don't know I don't know I well you got
one - sort of correct actually two
things are correct I do have a road Mike
and I do have a sony a7s so sony a7s -
not on and it's a road micro and my lens
it is a 16 or 35 f/4 Zeiss lens that I
use every single day for bargaining
everyday tight every day yeah I know we
don't talk about what [ __ ] runs you
have on there okay I don't know anyone
know what Mike is on there I do talk
about a lot that I'm stuck
okay now that we're in a arena of my
interests [ __ ] name my favourite
jiu-jitsu key that's blue one door brand
scramble doesn't feel like I want to
celebrate at all Yeah right isn't that a
funny feeling have experienced enough
all right how did I do in my first Jiu
Jitsu tournament um I think you finished
like between three and five like third
and fifth or something well you make it
easier for you wolves my record okay but
that's not fair that's the only thing
I've ever told you that's not yeah I've
seen the videos of it but like I don't
know how out of how many I don't know
how many
more matches you did three out of four
and then you got eliminated no like
there's a format it's how many did I win
- how many that was you won three and
you lost one no I want to in our last
200 this is so ridiculous
that was like 10 years ago sorry oh I
love you how am i doing
whatever okay well it's on YouTube and I
know you've watched over yeah but it
doesn't even say on there it's it's your
brother just telling you to stay happy
it does say on that oh my god okay i'm
so triggered right that's like me being
like in high school
what place that I finished my diving
meet as your diary I YouTube honestly
might be really I don't know well that's
ridiculous not ridiculous it's a fair
question
moving on we're fighting now all right
my best friend in high school in a dream
yes
Congrats shout out to answer the 50
Cent's all right sport not baseball that
I played a lot in high school it when I
was a high schooler not necessarily on
the team but I played a lot of
basketball no soccer soccer dodgeball
just guess if I played soccer a lot
warble warble ping-pong war boy loves
wear ball is so fun not ping-pong golf I
play a lot of golf okay it's all good
it's not a sport it's a hobby it's an
activity a name all right speaking of
golf follow-up question
what is my most amazing golf achievement
no that is so open-ended it oh my god
come on going tempo and a beautiful a
hole in one dish are three on a parsec
but need to hold on a par four it's
impossible
yes I had a whole lot of partners when I
they're par fours oh geez three and five
I was three four and five
no I'm fine what I'm a it was a par
three yes and I hit it and I have a
certificate of art and I lost the ball
but I had it for a while kite I got it
right so it's not glaze over there we
can we just like give me
props here braiding going on it's pretty
pretty amazing okay great thank you so
much oh babe it's okay we're out you're
not laughing you accomplice is just fun
okay um my first real job
I don't know Jillian I don't remember I
think I've talked about on the podcast
where you were an umpire yeah I would
say as my first legitimate job although
I did do private baseball lessons in
high school for a while another after
that if it all right sport Oh moving on
sorry huh my how many times have I been
surfing oh my god this is a hard one
I'll give you a kiss a hard one to one
um
name a birthmark that I have well you
don't have any birthmarks that's a trick
question
you did not what I have one on my butt
no you don't I have a right above my
butt that's like a mole it's a birthmark
right like hugely debate that that is a
birthmark you whip it out it's a
birthmark let me see run around let me
see [ __ ] out of here Oh perfect now what
a park-like looks like my head's on
chemo boy I swear to God I will fight
you I got that answer right boy daddy's
a [ __ ] mole just cuz you had it in
your kid doesn't make it a birthmark
oh good bye everybody no no I got that
right and you lot Iran that is a crappy
answer no is not a birthmark you take a
picture of that you tweet it out that is
a mole
don't you google birthmark they're flat
they're not raised this is flat no it's
just like a splat disco fun boy no it's
not
I think it is [ __ ] you no no I'm like a
treacherous flat earth is flat okay a
couple couple more [ __ ] a this one's
really hard tight so if you don't get it
don't feel bad what was my first gaming
console mmm Sega Dreamcast um Super
Nintendo yes it was I was like great
again I just wanted to say Sega
Dreamcast shop you know one first
console or Sega Dreamcast come on
someone's was someone somewhere out of a
lot of that do you
my favorite alcoholic drink there's a
lot of answers for this so well you like
Bloody Mary's you like Moscow mules um
you're like Tito's meat
so do I sir whatever no come on I'm not
doing all my long drinks you like sake
like whiskey whiskey okay there we go
correct got it favorite non-alcoholic
thing to drink orange juice intent do
you know I owe you 7 I said it before
you you'll show there would be nasty
yeah you better I feel great
I've never felt better babe you know
what little crabby everything cut that
bird somebody's crabby you needs a snack
you should get yourself a new sock all
of their snacks are made with zero
artificial crap and high-quality
ingredients you can trust fair snacks
that taste great and are delicious and
are good for you too I can step stop
snacking on the 20 bags they send us
something Charlie lemonade fruit stars
they are delicious I highly recommend
those nature boxes even better now you
can order as much as you want as often
as you want no minimum purchase and you
can cancel anytime so you go to nature
box calm and you look at their huge
snack catalogue there's over 100 snacks
choose the one you want and they'll
deliver it right to your door even if
you don't like it if you get a
replacement for free go to nature box
comrade now
giving you 50% off your first order did
I say 20% Naz manatees 50% off your
first order going to naturebox.com/tyler
doing some of the United States everyone
is always at your door some of the in
snack options are the strawberry stars
which I love sea salt chickpeas which
are so delicious but their chickpeas
they're out like not chips praline
pumpkin seeds seeds Fuji apples and
spicy sriracha popcorn that one spot
that one sucks Ellen Fox show do me and
these get yourself a pair of the best
underwear in the game right now they are
designed in LA sustainably sourced micro
modal fabric which is three times Optima
cotton and you know what I say this
every time but unless you sell two pair
of enemies you don't understand what
three times after the cotton feels like
until you are seen piranha pair and then
it changes the entire game okay it's
like a door other way yeah hashtag on
these on these come in an ever-changing
selection of classic color shades and
really fun patterns they just released
their new pizza print which I love that
one
and if you save if you can take yourself
some time money to get yourself a
monthly subscription right now if if you
go to nature about me and these calm
slash Emma and Julia me or nature box
welcome to so they'll give you 20% off
your first pair when you go to meet
andis calm so I send Julian so go do it
right now clean out that underwear
drawer get yourself some of the world's
most comfortable underwear and get them
every month yeah everyone needs new
underwear
always these bosses people like nothing
assembiy I'd be when your mom is that it
yeah
Julian alright sorry I had to rub it in
a little bit I feel like this is my
paper okay so I have a list here of
youtubers and their sayings and what
they call their fans and I want you yeah
some of them are fake there's a few
pairs like probably five or six fakes in
here and there's also one that's not a
youtuber it's just a famous person okay
alright here we go
does that bear here we go alright hey
[ __ ] it's me oh that sounds like Timmy
tomato hey babe it's me although you
might have done that
you stopped cursing a while ago it's not
to me to know what it is though no it's
not the one I read though you showed me
him the other day and I really liked him
he does make up Brett man rock fuckin'-a
okay
see some of these I got from you guys on
Instagram laughs oh I haven't even
compare means but we're taking your word
on them they just like supremely troll
you and there were a few trolls good
hello okay no idea okay maybe that was a
troll but someone says that's what Ali
speed says I have no idea that's sure
not someone confirm that please all
right here we go um ah good day
everybody okay these are billing data
not ridiculous is a very distinct one ah
good day everybody says ah
and good day Joey Graceffa yeah you know
it's why you causing a scene over here
Kermit tell your mom to get it together
please okay
top of the morning to you check septic a
you're doing well it can make sense all
of these makes sense subscribe and give
an alligator its wings okay no idea is
Adrian oh I was just gonna guess that
cuz that's the only one you got to give
me a second
damn I love bunny I saw her and Sanchez
she's my queen you love bunny yes what'd
you call her subscribers swamp swamp
swamp something's what Pam you got it
yeah nice job I know how to fake then I
like fun lot ah angle very nice eyes any
CD's up in the face life of it into that
head hi sisters you raising anybody you
recently tweeted lippy Kingsley it's not
what Kingsley says I don't know I just I
don't know make up
the James Charles oh look this is so
hard because there's a lot of context
they are all right I'll try to do a
better impression of them I'm doing
seriously please papa it's my guy stay
gorgeous oh GG good job I don't need a
high five every time you do really
they're not going to get a lot more so
I'm gonna give you a high five hey you
guys scarce here oh here's our Oh making
thought is good no not even when he says
because he's up you guys scares here
that's what I said scores here no you
missed something on burning and try to
turn to me what's up zombies oh that's
my geek Simon Gore Oh God who's flappy
brain your birthday excuse me to do a
decision yes yes yes that's also from
like the face flop when Julian did it
without you first time I ever dinner and
it looks yeah that's why we kept doing
it down favorite videos yeah because he
looks like him in the face flop but then
it sounds just [ __ ] what it was so
ridiculous that's Ryan Higa Jimmy what
did you call the fan um damn that's hard
I forget lamps question you got to give
me a second I didn't you say I forget
there was like three seconds of sound
this isn't jeopardy you're so angry at
me why is the way injury like there's
like a speed round spear I don't know no
okay so this is this is pretty big so
don't yell at me for this one but I
think they say something like let's talk
about that Bam Bam Bam good in the
morning that rhettandlink this job nice
job
this is actually the ending to their
what's their videos not the beginning
ready I still don't have a sign-off
Oh Gabi vlogs she does that her blocks I
still don't have a sign off I think
hi I'm like you know you could have done
a little research I did my research okay
see you all your life
no cuz I actually wrote boy okay so it's
done so beautiful bastards Philip
DeFranco I forgot to give you a couple
easy one future spirits back up okay
[Music]
I think that that's freely you know all
right sterling nice I feel like that's
fake eating its fake
yeah what the [ __ ] says oh it's a fandom
name yes I know mr. language no idea
Lindsey Stirling my dog [ __ ] idiot
babies okay I don't [ __ ] know they
call their fans idiot babies it sounds
like something wrong I would say but I
don't think I don't know I mean I'm he
would call people idiot baby video
babies it is a robotic mom ok hallo
everyone come on let's get a nurse it
seemed a logical well done
well I'm clean alright who calls their
fans showstoppers daddy nice nice
because I fans the armpit army
oh no that's like okay good no one does
all right this is their intro I mean in
Greece and Dolan who's that we're going
to yeah um let's see
moving on I said hit Grayson don't leave
me a [ __ ] comment or leave a [ __ ]
comment that's how they sign off these
are hard I didn't know some I don't know
that's drew Monson mmm I took hold in it
and I had to check out one but he does
he never like under his bad fig leaf
uncommon mm-hmm
the low game let's organ Paul yes the
Jake parlors ha ha ha ha okay yes go can
you go what up squad fam the best like
what Jack yeah that's a joke that's the
one I'd pick okay it's Jack's home all
right
you're over the same right you know it's
just hard summer little burgers come on
no it was Chris when he did that oh oh
that's not fair it is very smell very
good numbers yeah you did it as a joke
like one time a bit though yeah but this
is so obscure this one's not a youtuber
tight black stars sorry I know you might
not as avril lavigne presentation yeah
this is ridiculous I told you wasn't
youtuber okay um here we go let's see if
they end their videos like this Dubai
except that's like no no that was Tyler
Oakley and he did that one time
no he he does it no it's a video called
Shanghai and he just says as this one
time
and then dude I know it's one video
that's like three at least
no three or three or greater all right
we got a couple more um this is these
are hard though I feel bad all right do
it up you can live with your choices oh
my god you're just gonna keep getting
the enemy stay awesome Gotham doesn't
have to say that No who says that giving
you time be awesome Gotham oh is that an
economy well done like it's likes it I
don't know how to describe it it's like
weird in your brain because it's out of
context that's weird I don't doubt that
I just try to get some good trivia going
at all all right let's do one more
I'm cause they're fans huntys 15 colleen
ballinger calls her fans auntie
she says aunties all the time nope not
who I wrote down mmm no that's just a
word like people use yeah but they
specifically card fans if they're a duo
of vlogging duo superfruit no you say
hunty like this isn't fair Carly and
Aaron alright well now that jenna is
completely defeated that's it that's the
end of it can you not make me feel like
I just did the worst thing ever do you
like top of the morning to you is like a
concrete supposed to be on love you die
but those are just like some of those
are just like words and things that
people say no it's like the things they
say every video whatever am I wrong is
wrong no you know some of them were gray
area but I think I did okay yeah they're
okay right it is hard trivia is hard to
be on that end don't clean my beefy
voice my BB bullet anyway thank you
watching all right I feel sufficiently
like know how Julian feels he got me
back we're not I'm not laughing at you
this is what you tell me every time and
I'm serious like it you know what it
feels like I'm not trying to why I
didn't want you to feel like upset about
it I just want to say I just wanted to
do some trivia on stuff that wouldn't be
super easy yeah there's not much that I
can do like look there's not much you
know I like that I can do trivia on that
I know well or that I have in front of
me that youse all know well it's true
oh I'm sorry is my mom again probably
gonna take it off probably you're gonna
breathe into the night away with some
breathing Wow inside of my arm I was
breathing now thank you guys for having
such a good day today those cute oh
thank you I got a kiss for that Wow
all right we love you the lady Dan Baer
this is Jana - good job for you to know
we still love each other
yeah except we're breaking up of that
[ __ ] birthmark dog that is your she
already broke up I mean I really broke
up with me after you learn million we
hit two home run you want a real power
hitter I'm not a power hitter I did
[Music]
you
[Music]